yes citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tara
Erikson and I don't know why I have a terrible
exent that was awesome this is my H John um hrey
hey you got there I did it you got there how are
you John I'm good I'm wishing I had a better
Ryan Reynolds impression for you pretty good
I can do it sometimes it'll get better as the
movie goes okay all right I'd like to see it
who here has like a lowkey obsession with Ryan
Reynolds cuz me a little bit but it's from my
show Welcome to reom and you guys if you don't
know about it what's your favorite Ryan Reynolds
joint exactly you got to write it down right
now me currently my favorite Ron reynoldson
is welcome to rexim thanks for pre for helping
us edit down these videos also you get super
sex you got to get on the patreon you can sink
up with your own copy and watch most of all of
The Proposal with me and John also Greg and John
offer exclusive highlights and watch alongs over
there on patreon so if you go over there you get
sexy but not just like sexy he's like super sexy
like you see how he touch his butt and it burns
it's burning with SE okay are we ready to watch
it almost but you missed the most important
iconic part of the intro you got to leave a
like more important than leaving a like is the
part were you ring the bell ring the bell you
guys how did I forget that guys I'm not being
true to myself but thank God I in Christmas
gear and oh my God Santa I know him I know I'm
killing John's ears and I'm killing you guys but
we're going to get into we're going to watch the
proposal and get this three longest intro ever two
one
ooh I like this song I'm in
it I'm in it let's get it
oh it's like a really lowkey version of the evil
Deadshot wait now what movie is that oh
this song will get you going yeah man oh
plus what a great setup she can bike in the
city and in the woods all at the same time
Molen aeran Ah that's craigy Nelson you needed
set that clock though oh Betty White get out
of town you're my golden girl Tera here you
go your regular lattes literally saved my
life thank you thank hey oh she like is this
free guy right now maybe he wants a cappuccino
maybe he found his way he did it was a very very
you know portentous song yeah close one of those
mornings thank you Captain Obvious oh Jesus whoa
dude that was so loud yeah little pent up this
morning don't don't talk to you to you've had your
coffee trick that thing down leave the shirt off
your back literally you're kidding right Yankees
Boston this Tuesday two company seats for your
shirt you have 5 Seconds to decide 5 4 3 2 1
so quick quick countdown uh-oh everybody oh
it's she's she's called an it that means she's
a monster oh oh my God uh oh I'm terrified too
although she does look very good morning boss you
have conference call in 30 minutes yes about the
marketing of the spring books I know did you call
them what's her name the one the one with the the
ugly hands oh my your immigration lawyer called
he said that it's imperative he cancel the call
Push the meeting to tomorrow and keep the lawyer
on the sheets oh and get a hold of PR and have
them start drafting a press release Frank is
doing Oprah wow okay Queen who is Jillian and
why does she want me to call her a so cute well
that was originally my cup and I'm drinking your
coffee why because your coffee spilled oh no
murder him stab him in the gut so you drink
unsweetened cinnamon light soy lattes I do it's
like Christmas in a cup sounds delicious and
you would know I would I'm like Christmas
in a cup why are we headed to Bob's office
uh oh [Laughter] boy God this office chat whoa
have you finished the manuscript I gave you I
read a few pages that wasn't on impressed ouch
man I've read thousands of manuscripts and this
is the only one I've ever given you there's an
incredible novel in there the kind of Novel you
used to publish uh wrong oh no and I do think
you order the same coffee as I do just in case
you spill which is in fact pathetic how many
days has he not spilled it though yeah give him
a little credit witchy fearless leader and her
Le please do come in hey a man is it new it is
English Regency Egyptian Revival built in the
1800s but yes it is new to my [Music] office I
like the way you think I'm letting you go no no
why he just got a a hutch thing asked you over
a dozen times to get Frank to do Oprah and you
didn't do it a lot of times I have told you that
is impossible Frank hasn't done an interview in
20 years well that is interesting because I just
got off the phone with him and he is in oh bad
I will give you 2 months to find another job and
then you can tell everyone you resign okay ouch
okay well at least she's kind of nice about that
a little you poisonous [__] you can't fire
me oh fire me you are threatened by me Po stop
just because you have no semblance of a life oh
uhoh that you can treat all of us like your own
personal slaves you know what I feel sorry for
you mans is living the dream he's really getting
in there listen carefully Bob I didn't fire you
because I feel threatened I fired you because
you're lazy entitled incompetent and you spend
more time cheating on your wife than you do in
your office oo you are going out of here with an
armed escort Andrew will film it with this little
camera phone and he will put it on that internet
site was it YouTube exactly oh it's this is that
old we don't know about YouTube yeah come on
or at least put on e-bombs world this weekend
to help review his files in his manuscripts this
weekend you have a problem with that no I I just
my grandmother's not this weekend Grandma listen
I've worked too hard for this promotion to throw
it all away okay I'm sure the dad is pissed but
we take all of our submissions around here very
seriously and we'll get back to you as soon as
we can is that your family yes they tell you
to quit every single day oh yeah okay or going I
want to see upstairs immediately come get me in
10 minutes we've got a lot to doie do stressful
poor Ryan Reynold Ryan Reynolds working for the
weekend Margaret do you remember when we agreed
that you wouldn't go to the Frankfurt book fair
because you weren't allowed out of the country
while your visa application was being processed
yes I did she Canadian your visa application has
been denied that that and you are being deported
whoa what oh come on it's it's not like I'm even
an immigrant you've been pushing that meeting girl
I'm from Canada for Christ's sake there got to
be something we can do she's Canadian can't nice
your way out of this one unfortunately you have
to leave the country for at least a year okay
this is guitar tones until this is resolved I'm
going to turn operations over to Bob's faing the
guy I just fired if there was any way we could
make this thing work we'd be doing it there is
no way I I oh no oh there is what what Mary from
Miss Winfrey's office called I told her you were
otherwise engaged she insisted Mary all these
words oh no uhoh oh we were getting right to it
oh all right well I think there's something
that you should know H oh my goodness we're
uh we're getting married a with a pat we are
getting married we getting married yes is it
he your secretary assistant executive assistant
secretary promoted demoted and repromed all in
one conversation you know Andrew and I were
we are just two people who weren't meant to
fall in love but we did did face so dear in the
oh my God can't can't fight a can't can't fight
a can't fight a love like ours that's good such
great subtle physical comy yeah it's so good just
make it legal oh thank you very much gentlemen
we will do that right away thank you very much
gentlemen thank you gentlemen gentlemen who is the
gentleman behind the desk he looks so familiar oh
yeah he works like a ton uh I don't understand
what's happening they were going to make Bob
Chief so naturally I would have to marry you I'm
not going to marry you you sure you are because
if you don't marry me your dreams of touching
the lives of Millions with the written word are
dead yikes can't work for an American company
but I can torpedo you but don't worry after
the required allotment of time we'll get a quicky
divorce and be done with me but until then like it
or Not Your Wagon is hitched to mine okay although
there is something very very appealing about her
sense of authority that witch bro man yes cadabra
baby are you both committing fraud to avoid her
deportation so she can keep her position
as editor and chief at Cen books excellent
deductive reasoning sir let me explain to you the
process that's about to unfold step one I'll put
you each in a room and I'll ask you every little
question a real couple would know about each other
oh my you young man will have committed a felony
punishment by a fine of $250,000 and a stay of 5
years oh my good Federal Prison what they're both
beautiful just let them get married it's the way
the worlds just do it the truth is Margaret and I
are just two people who weren't supposed to fall
in love but did see knows the value of a good call
back good Motif we couldn't tell anyone we worked
with because of my my big promotion that I had
coming up promotion yes we both felt uh that it
would be uh deeply inappropriate if I were to
be promoted to editor while we were yeah have
the two of you told your parents about your secret
love impossible my parents are dead no brothers or
sisters either hey that's like me hey dude you're
Sandy B I am what are your parents dead no his his
are very much alive you're going to tell them this
weekend G's 90th birthday you thought it'd be a
nice surprise and where is this surprise going
to take place Sitka Sitka Alaska Alaska yes I
will see you both at 11:00 Monday warning for your
scheduled interview and your answers better match
up whenever you count W oh thing you said about
being promoted genius I was serious I'm looking
at a $250,000 fine in 5 years in jail that changes
things y yeah it does no then I quit and you're
screwed bye-bye Margaret really has been a little
slice Andrew Andrew fine wow fine and you'll
publish my manuscript yes yeah you tell give me a
cocktail napkin and a pen yeah now ask me nicely
to marry you get down on one knee what does that
mean you heard me on your knee yes oh my gosh no
way yes like a gentleman oh my oh but that skirt
yeah it would be hard yeah say it like you mean
it yes daddy sweet Andrew would you please put
Cher Eyes On Top Mar me okay I don't appreciate
the sarcasm but I'll do it the airport tomorrow
oh buddy sick burn I love their yeah like the way
their power Dynamic is Shifting and and the
way they're really not relying on suspension
of disbelief to sell this like it's so great
everything is like no these are the obstacles
good news is is I know everything about you but
the bad news is that you have 4 days to learn all
this about me so I should probably get studying do
you even care enough to learn what am I allergic
to pine nuts in the full spectrum of human emotion
do I have any scars I'm pretty sure that you have
a tattoo 2 years ago your dermatologist called
and asked about a q switch laser and found that
they in fact do remove tattoos so what is it
Japanese calligraphy barire yes whose Place do
we stay at yours or mine that's easy mine and
why wouldn't we stay at mine uh because I live
at Central Park West oh and you probably live at
some squalid little Studio Park with stacks of
yellow penguin classic rude don't knock my penguin
classics all right yellow is personality I [Music]
agree is that his mom hey oh love her of course
that would have to be gram gam gam would have
to be Betty W his mom plays the mom in all
romcoms in the 9s yes like she is the mom in
elf she's the mom in oh what other God she plays
mom in like Mary steam bgin is America's mom yes
she [Music] is O Bill Paxton okay a lot of Paxton
this is the person she needs to find and beat
down in front of everyone to establish dominance
agreed it's him oh my God he's a Paxton you didn't
tell me about all the family businesses honey
probably just being modest dear oh do we just
own the town yeah like the whole saying we just
own new Asgard over here look deep into my eyes
shouldn't we check into our hotel right now family
doesn't stay at a hotel you're going to stay in
our home great oh God you want to use your legs to
lift that one help her with those i' would love to
she won't let me do anything insists on doing it
all herself she one those uh she's feminist she's
a girl boss at the very least this is the last
of them oh my God it's Louis vuon Louis V I'm
not getting on that boat you don't have to see
in a few days you know I can't swim hence the
boat looking good boss she she's
going to fall yeah into his arms
[Music] a she he's in a light jacket guys you got
to learn how to swim let me just just learn how
to swim Primal skill the thing you should have on
a 70 to 80% water Planet yeah you got to know we
are wa she's like wow I had no idea who are you
people you thought so little of him and look at
him in his big mansion now yeah I wonder what
this movie would be like if it was just like a
modest studio apartment right or like a regular
family home in a sub would work for a romcom
one of them always has to be loaded that's true
you never told me you were rich I'm not rich my
parents are rich you know what that's something
only rich people say that's fair people need to
think that we are in love so it's just that that's
no problem I can do that I can pretend to be the
the doting fiance that that's easy you know but
for you it's it's going to require that you stop
snacking on children while they dream Margaret hi
pleasure so I always wanted to know what does a
book editor do that's a great question Louise
oh oh my gosh coach America's Dad look at him
why don't you tell us exactly what a book editor
does I mean besides taking writers out to lunch
and getting bombed h no wonder do you like being
an editor no no Andre is not an editor he's an
editor's assistant Maggie here is the editor oh
all right Dad slow it down what's your game you
show up here here after all this time with this
woman you hated and now she's your girlfriend
we just got here can we wait 2 seconds before we
throw the kitchen sink at each other just never
figured you for a guy who slipped his way to the
middle ouch she's my fiance getting married oo
okay hey hey look at him what's up that tradition
oh but see it's the the texture I'm not a a fish
person you're very very sweet I think you oh oh
right in the hole there to make Margaret and I
are getting married yeah come on down here pumpkin
pumpkin pump come on pumpkin brilliant brilliant
time Andrew uhoh oh is that his a hey hi wow and
we're being completely rude hi oh did I miss the
story about how you proposed oh how a man proposes
says a lot about his character H Andrew and I were
about to celebrate our first anniversary together
and I knew that he'd been itching to ask me to
marry him oh boy oh boy that's not exactly how it
happened no no the game is a foot she might find
this little box oh the decopage box that he made
tiny little pictures of himself yes just past it
all over the box so beautiful I miss decupage
yeah but inside that box with the address to a
hotel date and time real Humphrey Bogart type
stuff yeah Bogart [__] there he was standing
kneeling like a on a bed of rose petals in a
tuxedo and he was choking back soft soft SBS oh
my God and when he held back the tears and finally
caught his breath he said to me Margaret will you
marry me and she said yep yep hey let's see a
kiss I can see how she's an editor I could see
it yeah she can she can weave a yarn she can do
it ready is this on the Jesus man the best Winger
wingman oh Andy a real kiss a real one one
give us what we want just do it MH oh kind
of like it this is your bedroom wow this is um
beautiful The View and here's the bed thank you
here's the bed oh my God it's so cute you
are cute what a little puppy just rescued
him from the pound and he's still in training
sorry just be sure you don't let him outside
the Eagles will snatch him oh oh no good night
every everybody good night good night America's
mom you don't have a sleep mask yeah
right you seem like a sleep mask type
of person for sure yeah I agree and
earplugs too yes and a white noise
machine and a humidifier a whole thing
I mean she had like a whole screen of
like the woods to cycle with yeah hey oh
look at that and now we're ready for the
purge Andrew come business is calling uh oh
where is [Laughter] it Frank Frank darling you
there hello hello I have horrible service Frank
give me just just one minute oh my God Margaret
Jesus she's probably never sounded like this
over the phone before Oh sweet puppy dog cutest
dog I've ever seen the Eagles I love listening
to you Frank shh sit good boy a good boy no no
not you Frank no no you don't sit Frank Frank
no not the eagle the eagle will eat him they
are just so rich with we should all be privy
to and Frank I just uh I just I just want you
to be happy give me that not the puppy let
the puppy go holy [__] they really did
it oh my gosh I was so worried for the puppy
this movie wastes no time with anything it
really doesn't and and call me tomorrow with
your decision and my phone is oh my goodness
no oh love it no no take the oh jeez no not the
doggy take the dog take the do PI it Pi it it
a weaken barter we can work this out we thought
she didn't like him will you go get her Andy we
have a whole day planned for it yeah tell her we
have a big surprise for her uhoh I like surprises
okay that Eagle's going to like swallow her phone
yeah you drunk no I'm serious he's got my phone
and Frank's calling me on that phone relax right
we'll order another phone same number we'll go
into town tomorrow and we'll get it really yeah
I guess you can do that he solves problems where
are we with SIM cards how you're going out with
Mom and the girls I don't want to go shopping
sightseeing and a surprise give me a nice big
hug we don't think we're fighting I don't want
I don't want to oh there we go yeah you were the
one who said we got to sell this start selling
lady yeah you want to see me apparently I wasn't
the most gracious of hosts last night was a little
bit of a shock to find out that you're getting
married I owe you an apology you're a good guy
D I done a lot of things in my life practically
built an Empire with your mother from the ground
up it doesn't mean anything have someone to
leave it to yeah we've already discuss this
yeah I'd like to discuss it again oh yikes you
have responsibilities here but he wants to write
stories I need you to quit playing around here we
go again when are you going to start taking what I
do seriously yeah yeah I wish you had another son
I really do one who wanted to stay here one who
wanted to take over the family business one who
wanted to marry someone that you approve of but
it's not me now ouch it must seem strange to you
my life in New York sitting in an office reading
books but it makes me happy I love books know if
that's what makes you happy son I got nothing to
say then why the hell are you so sad yeah apology
not accepted your son isn't you sir he's his own
man yeah have another son yeah man just find
somebody else yeah thrust your Empire and your
legacy upon that child I agree I I hope you are
ready for your big surprise because this is one
of sika's greatest treasures right oh yeah oh is
it a stripper with like a moose head or something
what is this oh does she have to oh it's okay
you're going to love it oh yeah is it who's
going to be who's it going to be who's it going
to be hey my man this is just like when Buzz on
psych was also a stripper this is perfect don't
do it when you want to go to it relax Mo's the
only exotic dancer on the island but we're lucky
to get that Michael Jackson leg in there don't
do it over here I made $20 stripping once wow John
yeah yeah it's crazy oh my goodness true story for
another day Tera Ericson John's a stripper and
we didn't know it okay pluck my eyes out okay
all right oh bachelor party have a little fun yeah
it to Ramon Ramon let's go my man big respect yes
sir he's going for it and I respect it this is
great I respect it never be able to watch office
reruns the same way again nope oh my gosh keep
keep it in your mouth man smack his ass smack
his ass yeah time it right come on you can do
it [Music] no no no no hey there you are the
pxs can be a bit overwhelming at times you guys
are pretty serious huh well I mean we dated in
high school and all through college but we were
kids oh oh boy that's almost a decade that's a
long time you're a lucky girl he really is the
best a well cheers to you guys cheers that's
so nice cheers to you guys cheers to you guys so
sweet oh no uh oh what oh oh no what's going on
here oh yeah letting some inner rage out I've
always dreamed of doing this bad convo with a
dad so let's he you've dreamt of axing a log to
make a boat yes exactly exactly it's channeling
your rage into something constructive yes I would
love to go to a rage room yes oh hey I have never
what did you do I didn't do anything I mean I
just had a a Frank conversation with him about
his future yep I only get to see him every 3 years
because of you I've had enough you are going to be
supportive of him that's a sign you are going to
fix this Joe I mean it fix it now fix it Joe yeah
she just took the pants the family pants with
her mhm oh no mad cap naked scene oh and he's
going to get in with the fog he won't be able to
see oh no this all they have for a towel it's a
my oh my goodness my goodness I'm sorry let
me just let me just get Sandy be Sandy buns
Sandy Cheeks looking good oh look who
else is working oh hello this movie is
for everybody it really is H truly is
a feminist Fil A doggy he's so cute a
little budy you're only going to make
my fur fluffier and more adorable he
is so cute you like it get a pick of
it for like a calendar yes show the
world that's a good boy yes that's good boy come
[Applause] on oh yeah oh golly they're making
it on top of why are you why are you oh my good
why are you wet why are you atet jump me out of
nowhere what's that I didn't I didn't didn't mean
to jump you your dog was attacking me and I died
to run and I ran into you what is it with you and
this dog nice tattoo by the way what oh you see
that barely made it out with my life there yes
this is so great what's the deal with you and your
father oh I'm sorry that question is not in the
binder they give you specific questions to study
for but if the guy asked about that Margaret good
night just tell her open your heart come on man I
like the Psychic Network I took disco lessons in
the sixth grade my first concert was Rob Bas and
DJ easy rock don't like flowers in the house cuz
they remind me of funerals never played a video
game wow started twitch haven't slept with a man
in over a year and a half oh I thought it would
be longer yeah I went to the bathroom and cried
after Bob called me a poisonous [__] a she cried
oh in the uh bird tattoo they're swallows has to
do with their mom or something got them when
I was 16 after my parents died I knew it yep
yeah I'm sure there's many many other things but
it's all I can come up with right now it's great
framing with him in the negative space changing
and coming visually closer together Chang and
opening up the space in bed next great like you
could superimpose the shots to actually match
side by side right you really haven't slept with
anyone in 18 months oh my God yeah buddy who's Rob
Base and DJ uh easy rock yeah you know it takes
to you to make a thing go right oh yeah yeah I
know who they are I just wanted to hear you sing
it cute Margaret you are a very very beautiful
[Music]
woman God I can't see that looked like
a real moment oh so cute a that was so
cute that's lovely I really like this movie so far
me too really enjoying this breakfast
the couple Andrew Andrew Andrew Jesus
no are you wearing makeup no no of
course not oh my God I'm sorry it's
[Music] morning cinnamon rolls oh you shouldn't
have gone through that trouble that's oh your
family now it's no trouble oh hey you have
room for one more everyone's having breakfast
and bed oh your mother and I have come up with
a proposition and I happen to think it's it's
a terrific idea we want to get married here
tomorrow oh my goodness oh well you're going
to get married anyway so why don't you get
married here where we can be all together
and that way Grandma Annie can be a part of it
dude it's G's big birthday tomorrow night we we
don't want to ruin it that's you know that's I've
had 89 birthday parties I don't need another one
would be a dream come true for me to see my one
grandchild's wedding oh my gosh you got to give
it to Betty and you can get married like we did in
the barn it's a Paxton family tradition oh you're
Paxton now I've always wanted to get married
in a in a barn I have we're just so excited
EXC Grandma's always got crazy big rings and
stuff you could probably knock somebody's lights
out with one of those when my mom finds out that
this whole thing is a sham she's going to she's
going to be crushed and my grandmother's going
to die it's not like we're going to be married
forever be happily divorced before you know it
no but that's exactly what he's worried about
okay yeah that's the first time right now that
she's actually look how sheate with him yeah he's
like oh all right it might be okay get a quicky
divorce we'll be fine absolutely it's going to
be fine this little M better learn how to cook
so she can take care of her husband uh-oh just
have to focus Margaret Focus this is a business
deal just a business deal are you there God it's
me Margaret She's Got the Love Bug oh man she
got to go to the doctor and get that extracted
immediately yeah her business it's like a tick
leads to lime disease oh don't say lime disease
we just just watched a just watched a movie with a
weird te falling out sequence I don't want to know
it drums is she hearing that or is this
just the music is she time traveled is
it a time travel romance too I mean it's
a popular genre of literary fiction sure
is we'd be all right if it went there but I doubt
it oh SN it is a summon of spirits is I
Grandma Annie I see you are a curious one
come see how I give thanks to Mother Earth is
she one of those white people who's like 168
Chaka yeah just clings to that we must
give thanks and ask that your loins be
abundantly fertile sure follow and learn [Music]
he come on Margaret feel the rhythm of the drum
Wednesday Adams is just over there louder to the
window to the window to the walls to
the walls to the sweat drip down my
balls musical touchstones are
fascinating [__] this song must have
been very big at the time I'm assuming
it's fertility anthem of some kind Betty White's
face is so perfect shake it let me see you get
low you scared you scared drop your ass to
the floor you scared you scared let me see
you get you scared you scared God that was
all about the yin-yang twins in high school
boy yeah your gam wanted me to chant chant from
the heart balls you know it uh went went with
the beat your phone arrived let going go to
town and pick it up you want to come oh yes
I want to go I want to go hold on is it uh
is it okay if I I go with him whatever you
do is what shall be I know by KY first I
thought she disappeared thought she like
vanished like an actual witch doctor or
something oh my God it's so beautiful
now a boat together they're falling in love
every minute more how beautiful [__] I need
a computer is there is there a computer
in this God forsaken town is there pxton
Apple Store don't call it God forsaken you know
you're falling forward every minute God is out
there or maybe she gets jelly yeah she's going
to go she's going to get sad so it was nice to
see gertude huh yeah she looked really pretty
today a we're going to have to steal you away
young lady oh no no no no I'm I'm just going to no
not to worry no strippers no chanting in the woods
promise we're going for a Manny Petty I can't
believe this is happening oh they're going to
make our wedding dress wow love it because Annie
is the best tailor in Southeast Alaska oh damn
oh boy yeah buddy maybe a t Grandma had some big
ones n it's perfect this is how it's meant to fit
leaves a lot to the imagination to be knocked
up when I wore this let's see if we can find
your Savage Betty way this like an Easter egg
huh maybe they shrunk up in the cold Alaskan
Air all are good oh yeah agreed maybe we could
head down your way for the holidays that would
be nice that would be nice or maybe we could we
could come to you too you falling in love with
Alaska Grace for God's sake we've got work to do
I know sorry go make yourself a cup of tea I'll
finish this women their emotions am I right
always crying something turquoise one special
touch and you're ready it's been in the family
for more than 15 years it's it's beautiful but
I don't I'm not finished my great-grandfather
gave it to my great grandmother when they got
married they were quite a scandal you know why
he was Russian and she was clinking back then
you had to get approval from every member of
the tribe before you got married interesting
well how did they stay together then she was
a lot like you tough wouldn't take no for an
answer interesting is Betty actually part native
American curious about this plot through no no I
want you to have it I don't want to hear it it's
grandmothers love to give their stuff to their
grandchildren it makes us feel like we'll
still be part of your life lives even after
we're gone no just wanted to make sure there was
enough time to get all the sewing done don't you
worry about that you're going to be beautiful
that's sweet some there some lovely writing
across this even that story was like I forgot
I was watching like a script you know yeah TI
in there they go oh boy oh going for a she's not
having James Bond cruising sequence I forgot what
it was like to have a family forgot what
it felt like to have people love you and
make you breakfast no I'm just screwing it up
you're not screwing it up I agreed to this you
were there remember yeah they're not going
to find out you know they find no you know
my mother my God oh my God what if Gary finds
out if Gary finds out she's going to have a
[Music] this a great reversal oh there she
goes this is coming Pete great now now you
decide to shut up Mar no no save her go to
her she can surely make it to the red thing
yeah come on give me your hand hey give me your
hand oh come on give me your hand come come on
I got you I got you oh yeah that's right she
can't she can't swim yeah that's why he like
oh she could probably yeah she's probably
freaking out come here got to get warm come
on this is a really sweet moment yeah and like a
an actual legitimate yeah very real real moment
of of bonding and weathering something together
and like no words you could just tell she sighed
like into him and it was I got a phone call
from Mr Gilbertson here who told me that if
you were lying he would send you to prison so I
flew him up here wow dad oh wow you're going to
make a statement admitting this marriage is a
sham or you're going to go to prison you tell
the truth you're off the hook and she is going
to go back to Canada forever forever ever take
the deal I don't think so don't be stupid Andrew
you want a statement here's your statement I've
been working for Margaret tapate for 3 years 6
months ago we started dating we fell in love I
asked her to marry me she said yes oh boy all
right oh man and this guy's going to be at the
reception yeah you sure about this not really I
mean I am I am very appreciative of what you've
done but I think that you do the same for me hope
everyone is decent you need to come with me now
tomorrow is your wedding day you have to give the
baby maker a rest tonight yes ma'am give you br a
kiss good night and if you've got your whole lives
to be together okay yeah [Music] a my goodness get
that Cannon wowa wow it's so pretty that's a
barn it's beautiful yeah these Birch fronds so
pretty a that's so sweet yeah
maybe they'll admit it in the vows
I think they're she's going to have
to right cuz her whole look coming
down the aisle does not she looks too
conflicted oh my goodness
oh my gosh that was great so
good do you have a question uh no I I do have
something I need to say can it wait to after
nope nope nope nope read too many novels I
know how this works I uh I have a bit of an
announcement to make about the the wedding uh
I am a Canadian with an expired Visa who was
about to be deported because I didn't want to
leave this wonderful country of yours I forced
Andrew here to marry me see Andrew has always
had this extraordinary work ethic ah yeah and
for three years I watched him work hard than
anyone else at our company and I knew that
if I threatened to destroy his career he would
he would do just about anything real simp that
Andrew so I blackmailed him to come up here
and to lie to you and I thought it would be
easy to watch him do it jeez man turns out
it's not easy to ruin someone's life once
you find out how wonderful they are a that's so
sweet yeah you have a beautiful family don't let
this come between you a this was a business deal
and you held up your end but now the deal is off
wow well done you meet me
at the dock you're giving
me a ride to the airport yes ma'am all [Laughter]
right oh my god dude come on no chill just get
let me get my head on straight okay I'll explain
everything late go to her yeah going to do the
run the ROM come run to the airport run Ryan run
oh did she leave a note oh oh I did some coverage
of your work you were right this book is special I
lied because I knew publishing meant I'd lose you
as an assistant but you have an extraordinary eye
and I'll make sure we buy this before I leave a
that was uh crazy you know people are going to be
talking about this forever yeah yep it's going to
be part of my life now I just feel you know what
the problem is you see the problem is that this
woman is a gigantic pain in my ass I first there's
the whole leaving thing I totally understand that
you know it's a sham wedding I love the music cue
right here it's great she goes ahead and she
leaves this note three years I work with this
this terrorist but none of that matters because
we had a deal Andrew sorry you're bargaining with
yourself Andrew so you're just going to let her go
no you're not oh swim to her yeah go in that speed
boat you own call aquam man do some meta [__]
and get out there man you got this now that you're
leaving voluntarily It all becomes very civilized
you have 24 hours to head back to Canada dude is
it just for the year thing or do you do you have
to go forever now yeah I wonder Andrew Andrew
what's I got to talk to her why would you do that
says nothing to do is wait a minute I'm not going
to let you do this I mean it I'm not asking the
permission here listen to she's going to have
a somebody get a doctor easy oh no no dang
oh it's like in Moon struck where it's like
the mom is either dying or not dying depending
on if the the who's marrying the right person
oh speak to us Betty yeah tell him you
two need to stop fighting no you'll never
see eye to eye your family promise me a
you'll stand by Andrew even if you don't
agree with this family business not
business Family Promise me you work
work harder to be a part of this family the
spirits can take me no it's not your time
no she joking I guess they not ready for me
oh my goodness oh my goodness I love it a on
well was the only way I could get you two
to shut up and get us to the airport love
it she's a good one yeah you made me cry it's
messed up Betty White up back in New York I'm
like Elliot in this always get my man dude not
now Bo this guy is a lot now man he's too much1
as soon as you're in position you're this guy
it's his boy yeah it's his friend it's going
to it's going to come in handy he's going to
cause all sorts of air traffic control type
chaos run Ryan run run run Reynolds to okay
I have a little favor I need from you buddy
uh Margaret's on that plane I got to talk to her
can you stop it oh yeah I heard about your lady
Balon drag Ola Chuck stop the plane please teach
you not to be a drag over right now stop it stop
it no no no come on oh my God you're going to have
to chase the plane down with another plane you're
airplane Chase come on let's do it shoot it down
let's do it if she didn't love him she wouldn't
have left course am I the only one getting we
got to get Rachel off the plane get off the
plane R and
Hunt none of them know her like Ryan renolds does
now no one sees the human in side Sandy P Sandy
P what what oh he came oh my gosh in the middle of
the office oh this is even more embarrassing than
an airport I need to talk to you yeah well I don't
have time to talk I need to catch a 545 to Toronto
I need the box to go out today I want to make sure
everything is Margaret stop talking 3 days ago I
loathed you I used to dream about you getting
hit by a cat and we had our little Adventure up
in Alaska and things started to change things
changed when we kissed when he told me about
your tattoo even when you checked me out when we
were naked when we got real nak oh well well well
I've been naked once before but I didn't realize
any of this until I was standing alone in a barn
oh wifeless wifeless the woman I love is about to
be kicked out out of the country he wouldn't have
put all that up with all that abuse if he didn't
love yeah for 3 years marry me a because I'd like
to date you that's a great line in context that's
lovely that's awesome there's a reason why I've
been alone all this time I'm comfortable that
way and I think it would just be a lot easier
if we forgot everything that happened no don't
go into denial give him a choice between what
is right and what is easy that would be easier
I'm [Laughter] scared very human thought oh that
guy that guy is really enjoying this you supposed
to get down on your knee or something
I'm going take that as a yes yeah buddy
oh damn oh they make it out now
yeah do it in front of everybody
consummate this marriage you two
are engaged again yes yes for real
this time for real yeah a just because
one wrong answer I'm going to take you
down
okay okay fun version of this Trope as
well nice nicely done I like the call
to the song that's right man when did you
first start to date last week oh is that
going well so far it's great thank you
does Andrew use men's Speed Stick what
flavor Alpine was it Love at First is it
flavor or a scent I loved her from the
beginning iide the bed you sleep on look hey
will they kill each other no you fair we don't
use the word Margaret around Kevin he still
hasn't warmed up to her oh oh my God Kevin is
so she farts her sleep oh no it's not true girls
don't have that part of their body no I call him
uh puppy pumpkin monkey Daisy kiddo oh oh no
well when you say you know the position in the
relationship top or [Music] bottom he knew
your favorite color green blue wrong white
white favorite color is blue what's her favorite
color when she's not at home when she's not at
home yes I'm a citiz are you crazy oh no raon
who are you engaged to Andrew good got one no
who are you engaged to I'm engaged to Margaret
Tate and on the wedding day who will be next to
you but is this a game show I don't understand
what this is a fascinating medly of moments
that stand oh goodness land that I love oh my good
if you're listening to this on Apple Spotify leave
a rate and review give it a thumbs up do all
the things give it some Stars you you know how
to do how to do it Absolut love this movie I did
too oh my God yeah no this was so delightful and
like you know I I love a good romance I'm often
sitting here with the kinds of movies we more
often en enjoying and taking thinking like oh man
would love some romance I can get behind you know
especially modern movies like there are times when
you're like oh cool this doesn't have to be a love
story but now I feel like we've done a lot of that
so now uh you know I'm always like yeah bring me
some love but I love this uh cuz uh cuz yeah this
had all the like you know High Jinks and ups and
downs of a of a romantic comedy but it was just
like an actual Romance movie you know yeah like it
followed all of the tropes of like the run to the
airport the The Strife that happens and like how
they end up falling for each other but there were
so many real moments that it was like you can't
even be like oh this is supposed to be funny it's
like all of it during the whole time with physical
humor as well as the pacing and the tone funny
when it needed to be and the times when it was
like serious without them like really Hamming it
up it was just so real especially like the first
time that you know know um she starts sharing
with him in in the bed like all of the things
that uh she likes finds finds attractive all the
stuff about her um and as you said like that the
camera was moving from one side to the other to
basically change a point of view like that is
when the switch happened I think more so between
them and it was just such a beautiful like moment
and that this movie was filled with it like when
she was with the grandma with the dress I was like
this is so touching and grandma in the plain like
there are some serious little um uh little spouts
from every character like giving these monologues
that normally I feel like in a romcom would feel
like we get it let him just get this like Trope
over with I never felt like this in this movie
never felt felt all real yeah it never felt like
a yeah exactly it's like it has all the it felt
like reading some kind of romance novel in that
everything was well fleshed out everything was
cons ious it didn't rest on I mean you know it's
the perfect proposal for a movie you know like
oh yeah the Green Card wedding and you know this
particular power Dynamic and they're going to go
through all the crazy hinks of yeah learning to
actually maybe like and perhaps even love each
other but yeah it never and not to slight other
romantic comedies that are more overtly just
trying to have fun being that genre but yeah
there's something about this that felt a bit
different and it doesn't feel like a a medley of
tropes gleefully strung together like the tropes
are in there but it all felt pretty natural just
because of the circumstances and so yeah you have
you know you don't get too wild and too wacky it's
not like meet the parents or something where you
know it's going to get gross out or anything like
that um and I love that yeah it's like you've got
her as a Canadian you know in this position to
be deported you got Ryan Reynolds Canadian actor
you know that's fun is this Sandy Canadian too I
don't know I don't know uh but but yeah like it's
such a you could easily have made this a wacky or
raunchier comedy but I thought this was just the
right amount of everything kind of cuz you know
like it is kind of steamy at certain moments but
it's not like uh uh I don't know broy about it
it's not like off-putting or or runchy in that
respect um and then like the little moments of
you know genuine romance feel genuine and I love
the interplay of like when you can tell she is
starting to open up to him uh and the small ways
in which he you know uh assumes you know a greater
power position because they're on his Turf now and
takes a little bit longer to kind of open up to
her and the back and forth of the journey getting
them to the end felt really well earned and well
observed and and it never felt can't think of
anything that really felt like a contrivance
because we need something to happen and the
audience will forgive us because you know as long
as the chemistry is good we're fine you know like
it it never like I was really kind of impressed
cuz there's some really lovely Direction in here
it's smartly written and uh and like I don't know
a ton of uh an Fletchers other stuff but I thought
this had like just the right amount of like it's
not inyour face with style choices necessarily
but it's like really nicely paced and the again
the way it's photographed and the way it uses
its settings is really nice and the way again in
some of those scenes it's visually representing
the changing in their Dynamics I just thought was
like really uh kind of subtle and and and uh and
uh graceful I guess is is the word I'm looking
for graceful is good yeah I also thought that
in the in the scene where she drowns because the
the writing in here is so good but like one Trope
is like oh of course she's gonna fall off the
boat and like she can't swim right so he's got
to save her that is a Trope that we would see and
I think specifically with the direction is what I
saw there is what I really truly liked is that the
direction was like no you can't swim like you're
going to be hanging on to this and you're probably
like Frozen in fear meaning you can't move and
that moment to me was like so real because any
other director or you know possible thing of like
oh it's funny she falls off the boat and of course
you got to pick put her back in and like you got
to warm her up and now you got to like you get to
hold her but all of that was was was just done so
grounded and so real and I love that I assume the
direction was like Hey like you can't swim you're
panicking he's really got to like basically peel
you off this buoy and then when he does like hold
you it's like you don't you're so amped up and
now you you have no reason to like not even dive
into him and at that time and need someone yeah
some benevolent yeah cuz in in another movie that
might have been played Just for wackiness yeah
and bigger and broader for a romcom world and
that was so real yeah and and I love the way it
straddled that line because again so many of these
moments could easily play out in a in a different
tonality but yeah like that bit where he they're
kening toward the buoy it's like a natural reason
you would swerve and then I had that moment when
she's like strugg Ling to take the hand off of
it to to reach out for him I my initial thought
was well just reach out to him like you're just in
the water but then I I realized in that moment the
the plot Point hit me and I was like oh yeah like
you said that would be traumatic and terrifying
and you're probably just trying to clutch to any
solid thing and probably not wanting to let go
and even later on in the movie where you know she
leaves and he is you know sort of bargaining with
the situation and he's all frustrated now because
he's like spiraled out of control the situation
that he did have sort of under what felt like a
kind of control is now beyond that for him and
then she is in like trying to deny the feelings
outright and just be like you know what I'm just
going to leave it's fine like the the way they
still had those very human it's not just like oh
well now he has to go to her and she will say
yes and everything will be okay it's like I I
like that they took the time for each of those
moments to have they say that like every scene
should have a dynamic and have like a structure or
have little acts to it and I feel like this movie
was good at doing that yeah uh cuz yeah there
are so many this is the kind of movie that on
Surface you wouldn't expect to rely so heavily
on its actors but and and not to say that any
other element is FL uh flagging or anything but
yeah the actors across this have you know their
natural charms to bring but also everybody has
their own feelings and there at least you know
you get light looks into the family Dynamic and
yeah you have Grandma who is very much you know
the warm sort of encouraging presence and then
you have mom who's sort of stuck in the middle and
like you know Dad is wants the best for you but is
being overbearing and is overstepping boundaries
and mom's trying to hold it all together and and
all those things registered really naturally and
then when they start splitting off the characters
like yeah you have freaking raon stripping which
is fun and delightful and I was totally there
for it and I feel like the movie earns you know
when it decides to jump into absurdity and uh
and yeah and that was an example of something
more Fantastical about this movie that I I am a
sucker for that Trope of like the same guy works
everywhere in town he's got every job uh yeah and
uh and even the guy the agent comes out and they
didn't have to do any crazy thing where we put
laxatives in his coffee or something like that
you know oh my God like you know it was classic
I feel like this is one of those movies where
I'm like no matter who you got cast as if you're
a character it seems like every every body got
to bring some of their chops and yeah it's a
great combination of director and script and
it's awesome to see a movie where I mean Sandra
bulock uh has given many Great Performances and
Ryan Reynolds has two but I like to see a movie
again I miss the time when Ryan Reynolds wasn't
just the Ryan Reynolds of today where like every
role is his particular brand of of demeanor and
everything is kind of Ryan Reynolds SL Deadpool
except ironically Deadpool cuz at least he's not
beautiful in that role right so to see him here
in a role that yeah capitalizes on his innate
voice and charm it also felt like he's actually
playing a character and actually in a situation
rather than a movie is happening around him yeah
I agree yeah and that was just so so gratifying
and yeah I was I got all the things I laughed I
cried I got you know worked up I'm curious I want
to find out is a is is Betty White of indigenous
Heritage cuz that's one of those um you know like
she goes out into the woods and she's like dancing
with her and they're doing this like ceremony um
okay so she was of Danish Greek English and wealth
just it's an interesting choice for that character
cuz part of me was like I wonder if they did
this because because she actually is or yeah
yeah or you know if uh if this is an element it's
like they're in Alaska so I would have to imagine
that if you're if you have grown up there maybe
there's a chance a probability that you might
have some indigenous roots to you right um yeah
see like so that's a bit problematic that she is
you know the character I guess by now standards
versus 2009 like I wasn't seeing there like I
am offended but in in in other if this was made
today I feel like you would cast somebody with a
bit of that you know Heritage and I like that
that I really liked her story when she's like
yeah my uh my parents they didn't approve groove
of their Union cuz he was Russian and I forget
what tribe she mentioned but like it's part of the
character it's not like a goofy FR it's kind of
goofy that scene is perhaps I guess the most Pro
the The Proposal in and of itself is problematic
but that's part of the fun if there's something
that's truly like kind of like oh interesting
again I wasn't upset but I am also like ah this
is kind of like a way this hasn't aged the best
but even in that today that wouldn't exist yeah
or or again it would exist with a slight different
casting decision without a white woman probably
playing it is yeah but as far as those things go
too it's like I'm kind of searching around for
some kind of you know criticism in that I have
any cuz everything yeah just it flowed so nicely
and I love that this I don't know like not that
every romantic movie should be this but this had
all the joys I get out of watching a romantic
comedy but also just like all the joys I get out
of watching like a solidly executed and conceived
film yeah yeah and and Sandra be like she always
delivers but she really it it's in the moments
where she doesn't say anything and you know what
she's feeling and she's on the verge of like tears
when or she feels really hurt when he in the
cinnamon rolls with a bed and you just see it
in her face and then you see it in her face when
she's with the grandma and you see it in her face
when she's coming down the aisle so when you say
like this film relies so heavily on actors I think
like the biggest thing and I'm a firm believer in
it is that half of your job is done with really
good casting and I think that's half of directing
is being like this was cast we cast everybody for
a reason yeah and then you don't really have to
stress as a director because you're not going to
have to be redirecting or giving line reads right
you're just like oh these people I trust them and
we can just roll and just focus really more on
the vision of how you want it to come to life
um which is awesome and I I assume like it was
kind of a breeze working with these actors and I
I like loved it yeah one too I mean like they just
a couple straight things like I think for example
Molen Akerman is a great casting choice because
you see her and you think of what kind of a movie
you're in you're like oh I know where this is
going and it never goes there and it lets her use
her natural charm her those electric blue eyes you
know she's she's lovely but there's never really
aside from like the natural insecurity there's
never really any mellow you know contrived out
of that I think she's not trying to win him back
the whole time or like secretly in love with him
or trying to like make the other girl look bad
there wasn't any of that which is great yeah they
just acknowledge it and it's a it's an anxiety
to some extent but then they you know they yeah
they use it just appropriately and it's a great
combination yeah of casting with yeah what kind of
moment we're in and uh and yeah and even just the
way that they're two characters cuz also you look
at the beginning and you're like she is completely
overbearing and he is completely spineless right
and you can see how that is a toxic Loop for sure
but by the end you can also see especially with
her just I thought that whole I thought that was
played really nicely cuz it's so easy to be lost
in the surface of their you know Odd Couple back
and forth but when she's like no you have a family
you have people who care about you and who like
want to have a connection with you that you could
actually be fostering and instead you're just
like selling all of your soul to me Y and so
like after that point it just feels like oh but
I can I can see how Opposites Attract and I can
see how this Dynamic that we started with with a
little bit of emotional conne connection growth
and letting go of certain baggage could lead
to two people who are actually well equipped
to lift each other up in different ways so like
that was another cool thing I wasn't like oh
this toxicity is just erased out and they're
great perfect people it's no it made sense
how they could get there yeah and then ending it
on the interview that you know is going to still
be a [__] show I think is is lovely like and
you're watching the credits and I think that's
appropriate because it exists outside the movie
and you're like okay everyone's getting all the
answers wrong so like you know I don't know how
this is going to go but yeah at the same time
yeah chef's kiss man I I had such a lovely time
with this Bravo like this is a movie that I would
rewatch like that I'd go oh yeah buy this movie
like seriously I loved it so much I would show
this movie to people in fact too I saw a thing
I can't remember what it was it was something it
was like what's your favorite maybe it's even
just like a random tweet thrown out there of
like what's your favorite holiday movie that's
not overtly a holiday movie that just either
happens to feature a holiday or you know is just
one that you know during a family setting you know
it probably go over pretty well and like this is
a movie that kind of came to mind just now I was
like you know what this isn't a Christmas movie
but you know you're in Alaska you're in the vibe
and it's like it's snowy and it's heartwarming
by the end but it's also you know it's going to
hit you in the fields too I'm like yeah it's
basically a Christmas movie Just without the
decorations cuz if there were decorations there
it would just be like oh it's a Christmas movie
they just don't talk about it cuz everything is
like has that like cozy like Aline like I loved
it good job excellent like Bravo we love this
movie we would share it we also love you so much
leave your thoughts down below how much did you
love it yes and what other romcoms maybe should
we watch I don't know you know lot of Classics I'm
not seen yeah give us some juice you know we love
it we love you so much get real reject you know
like a t-shirt if you haven't gotten it already
get on patreon do the right things you know what
I mean [__] Le would approve get together we
love you so much that's all we got for you and
we will see you on the next one bye [Music]